théâtre à présent avec une pièce
proposée par la 3 bis et compagnie à
toulouse à la cave poésie du tort une
pièce de molière l'école des femmes pour
en parler
jean marc brisset mon invité en
compagnie de marina foïs qui est
comédienne jean-marc étant donc sur
cette pièce le metteur en scène jean
marc choc ce serait bien sans tomber
dans les excès de l'explication de texte
c'est pas le moment ni le lieu de
résumer un petit peu la pièce est bien
l'école des femmes c'est moi je les ai
vus comme ça c'est la tragédie d'un
homme névrosé complètement jusqu'à la
folie par la phobie du cocuage et qui
est quand même malgré tout décidé de se
marier et il pense
arnolphe donc que pour se marier
d'éviter d'être cocu le meilleur moyen
c'est d'épouser une idiote
il a donc fait lever pendant 17 ans une
jeune fille agnès dans un couvent il a
sorti de ce couvent et la pièce commence
il a décidé de l'épouser le soir même
voilà mais ces dessins sont nés l'a
injurié il faut le dire tout va se
passer très très mal pour lui
en effet pendant qu'il était parti en
vacances pendant dix jours à la campagne
et quand il revient il apprend qu agnès
a rencontré un jeune homme pendant son
absence
et là la jeune idiote va finalement
devenir une jeune fille intelligente si
on veut même cruel a féminine aux soins
alors la cruelle involontaire agnès
c'est marina foïs qui est là
je j'hésite mais je veux le faire c'est
complètement discourtois demander l'âge
des jeunes femmes mais là j'avais 16 ans
et moi j'irais volontiers jean marc
agnès alias marina quand même étonnant
de précocité
on peut dire ça oui je pense à ça qu'on
l'a choisi c'est pour ça que je les
choisis non je vois qu'il ya une sorte
de l'histoire d'amitié d'entre entre
vous deux comment ce fait-il marina que
habitant paris suivant des cours à paris
vous soyez à toulouse à la cave poésie
racontez nous ce n'est pas ce que je
connais jean marc depuis très longtemps
il a été quand j'ai commencé à faire du
théâtre j'avais 7 ans comme ça j'en sais
des cours dans une mjc et jean marc
était mon prof et puis j'ai on n'a
jamais perdu vraiment contactez moi j'ai
vu plusieurs spectacles de troyes b c et
où et quand il a cherché agnès et ben il
a pensé à moi non mais c'était pas par
amitié en fait c'était parce que bah si
quand même ça un peu jour il m'a fait un
pas du tout un lac a même dit ah bon
parce que marley venus passer une
audition je lui ai demandé de venir
passer un week-end à toulouse on a fait
des lectures on a travaillé et j'ai pris
ma décision donc pendant pendant la
semaine qui a suivi et je lui ai demandé
de revenir sur toulouse
non non c'est important comme premier
rôle enfin un des premiers rôles que
d'internautes et agnes c'est important
parce que c'est la première expérience
professionnelle que j'ai et j'ai de la
chance de tomber sur un rôle comme ça
qui est un rôle important et intéressant
parce que il ya toute une évolution du
personnage au cours de la pièce c'est
très dur de me montrer justement
commandes
au départ elle est à la limite de la
bêtise profonde parce que elle est très
innocente qu'elle ne connaît rien et qu
elle est naïve et tout est que à la fin
devient promet une femme émancipée
intelligente qui est capable de prendre
une décision et qui fait même preuve de
beaucoup de courage et d'une grande
force intérieure mais que faisait-il
temps se jurait qu'il m'aimait d'une
amour sans secondes et me disaient les
mots les plus anti du monde des choses
que jamais rien ne peut égaler est bon
toutes les fois que j'en entends parler
ça me chatouille et là dedans remous
certains je ne sais quoi dont je suis
tout ému aux fâcheuses examen d'un
mystère fatale ou l'examinateur souffre
au sol tout le mal
[Musique]